a function is nothing but a box like
this it takes an input performs an
operation on it and gives an output if I
feed two into this box it gives us 10
when I feed 4 into it it gives us 20 and
when I feed seven it gives us an output
of 35 what is this box doing to the
inputs you would have probably guessed
it is just multiplying the inputs by
five two times five is ten four times
five is twenty and seven times five is
thirty-five this is the function but
there has to be a way in which this
function is written yes it's most
commonly written as f of X is equal to
5x what does this tell us what's written
within the brackets is the input to this
function and what we get is the output
if X is 2 then the output will be 5
times 2 which is 10 does it have to be X
nope we can also write it as f of a is
equal to 5 a if we input the value a we
get an output of 5 a so f of something
generally means function of does it have
to be an F again not necessarily we can
say that G of X is equal to 5x G is a
function which multiplies 5 to the input
and gives us an output so don't get
confused if you see some other letter as
the function name here's one final way
in which this can be written y is equal
to f of X is equal to 5 X Y is also you
sometimes to write the output let's
understand this well Y is equal to f of
X is equal to 5x what will happen for X
equal to 2 as the input Y will be equal
to F of 2 it is a function which takes
the value of X as the input and
five X as the output five times two is
ten we are just using Y instead of f of
X because it's a little easier to write
it for X equal to two the output Y will
equal 10 and what if X is 4 y will be F
of 4 and 5 times 4 is 20 so don't get
confused when you see a Y or a G or an F
the meaning of the function does not
change sometimes we might have a
variable input look at this function G
of a is equal to 2a squared what would
be G of B plus 2 easy we just substitute
B plus 2 in place of a it will equal 2
times B plus 2 squared all we really
need to do in functions is substitute
the input value and get the output
you